[Music]
hello everyone it's me claire and i'm
back for another ipad video it's the new
12.9 inch ipad pro which comes with the
new m1 chip not only that there's a new
liquid retina xdr display which only
comes in the 12 inch model i'm trying to
get it out of the box and looks pretty
big compared to my ipad app i'll do a
comparison later between the two devices
so what's the most obvious way to
recognize the ipad pro 2021
check out the huge camera module at the
back of the ipad it looks exactly like
the ones from the iphone 12. new to the
2021 model is a lidar scanner as well
now try my best to see how it can
actually work with procreate we'll have
to wait for the 5.2 version update for
that the new feature allows users to do
3d modeling they use the lidar to create
air models within procreate now that
it's out of the box let me get it on the
magic keyboard i've gotten the white one
now and it seems like it can get dirty
really easily let's see how it holds up
over time now i've gotten the ipad pro
2021 and ipad air next to each other and
it's easy to tell the difference the
ipad pro is really much bigger in size
i've got both a maximum brightness and
it's quite apparent how bright the new
ipad is
i'm going to test it with a video on
youtube and see how it goes
both of the video settings are now at 4k
resolution
but it's going to be quite apparent that
both panels are not equal it is clear
that the ipad pro 2021 has the superior
display in terms of blacks and colors
come out much more vibrant than they do
on the ipad app
it brings new meaning to that term high
definition
at the start the difference in color
quality isn't that obvious with the
fruits and pot what really makes the
quality display stand out were the
textures of the bubbles
and the high contrast between the
highlights and shadows
the liquid retina xdr display of the
ipad pro 2021 quickly creates a sense of
awe in the viewer as the video
progresses
and that's it for now i'll be back soon
with the full video where i compare my
thoughts between the ipad pro 2021 and
ipad air drawing experience
if there's any feature you'd like me to
check out for fellow creatives let me
know down below remember to like comment
and subscribe
[Music]